monsieur le Premier ministre nous
connaissons votre bilan c'est celui du
président de la République la crise du
logement la crise de l'hôpital la crise
agricole la crise de l'école la crise
sociale la crise des salaires la crise
des finances publiques c'est la réforme
de l'assurance chômage la réforme du RSA
la réforme des retraites c'est aussi ce
moment coupable de bascule politique et
moral avec la loi immigration lorsque
vous avez cédé à la droite et à
l'extrême droite nous connaissons
désormais votre projet c'est celui du
président de la républiqueb les
conservateurs la cohabitation assumée
avec la droite dont vous conduisez
désormais la politique nous pourrionss
l'end parler de vous mais je veux parler
des Français car notre rôle d'opposition
c'est de convertir l'alerte en
perspective et la critique en action les
Français souffrent le pays souffre et le
mal qui le ronge c'est
l'injustice alors que vous préparez déjà
une nouvelle réforme du marché du
travail et de l'assurance chômage faite
de mauvais coup vous prétendez défendre
la valeur travail nous défendons pour
notre part la valeur du travail et nous
voulons que la valeur change de camp
qu'elle ne soit plus du côté des
rentiers des actionnaires et des
rémunérations extravagantes mais du côté
du travail et des travailleurs nous
défendons la France des ronds-points des
sous-préfectures vous défender la France
du rond-point des champs- Élysées nous
voulons que le travail paye et qu'il
paye bien pas de cette France de
travailleur pauvre nous défendons
l'égalisation de la fiscalité du capital
et du travail la taxation des
multinationales et des super profits un
juste partage de la valeur pas vous nous
défendons l'augmentation des salaires
indexés sur l'inflation une limitation
des écarts de rémunération de 1 à 20 pas
vous nous voulons que la valeur soit du
côté de l'utilité social l'heure est
venue d'une radicale reconsidération
morale et économique des métiers du soin
nous avons besoin plus que jamais des
infirmières des aides à domicile des
assistants d'éducation des aides
soignantes nous voulons bâtir un modèle
économique pour le 21e siècle où le
travail est mis au service de la pleine
santé vous parlez d'emploi nous voulons
parler de travail des conditions de
travail de santé au travail du temps de
travail et du temps libéré de
l'organisation du travail et des
processus de production le temps de
travail et le travail comme mise en
commun et but partagé nous défendons
pour cela le dialogue social le dialogue
professionnel et la codétermination dans
l'entreprise dont il faut se débarrasser
ce n'est pas du travail les gens aiment
leur métier mais des rapports de
domination vous voulez libéraliser
ubériser le travail nous voulons
toujours mieux le civiliser nous
défendons le travail qui émancipe digne
et porteur de
sens vivre dignement c'est aussi pour
beaucoup de nos compatriotes compter sur
nos services publics si durement attaqué
par vos réformes quand les S social de
service public reculent les inégalités
avance et les injustices prospèr les
Français les plus modestes sans
interlocuteurs au pris avec des services
sociaux chamboulés par l'austérité
fragilisé par vos réformes toujours
suspicieuses en sont comme toujours les
premières
victimes ce qui caractérise le présent
et plus encore l'avenir c'est
l'incertitude qui trie les VI qui laisse
les plus fragiles sur le bord du chemin
ce que nous devons imaginer ce sont les
services publics de demain et c'est une
sociale qui apprivoise le hasard l'état
social de demain c'est celui du retour à
l'universel qui n'oublie pas les
catégories et les classes moyennes qui
trop souvent ont le sentiment de n'avoir
droit à rien c'est-à-dire des services
publics étendus pour tous des droits et
des mécanismes de solidarité qui sont
notre capital commun l'universel ce sont
des droits pour tous plutôt que des
allocations pour certains l'universel
c'est l'extension des services publics
et leur gratuité comme dans les
transports publics par exemple
l'univ c'est l'assurance maladie
obligatoire à 100% pour tous c'est
jeunesse le repas 1 € c'est demain la
sécurité sociale alimentaire et la
garantie universelle des loyers c'est
aussi une réflexion exigeante sur la
gestion de nos bien commun la terre
l'eau leur partage et leur accaparement
ce qui doit être laissé ou retiré au
March les épad
Lesch devant votre Ministre c'est la
mixité sociale à l'école la ségrégation
mine la cohésion nationale aboudissant
au repli sur soi pour les uns et à la
sécession pour les autres nous devons
avoir un objectif supérieur étudier
ensemble pour vivre ensemble car seule
l'expérience est universalisante et ce
n'est pas votre SNU qui remédiera à des
années de séparatisme social
l'instruction publque reste
indubitablement le ciment de la
République contre toutes les grandes
féodalités sociales religieuse
économique et territoriale mais aussi
contre toutes les forces de la désunion
nationale c'est comme cela que l'on
ramène à la République par la République
et je le dis aux obsudés du réarmement
civique et de la régénération aux
inquiets de la décivilisation la
République sociale c'est au fond la
meilleure façon de prendre en charge le
sentiment national c'est la seule voie
pour se monter l'éter dilemme entre la
recherche de l'universel et
l'affirmation du particulier
la République c'est ce qui nous
distingue est pour nous une forme de vie
collective fondée sur la recherche de
l'égalité comme base des relation social
et comme mode de production du
commun généreux de mots nous avons
entendu et avar d'acte votre bilan
environnemental est un dépôt de bilan
jamais la crise n'aura paru ni plus
tangible ni plus violente ni porté aussi
nettement son cortège d'injustice et
d'inégalité tandis que prospère des des
richesses et des modes de vie
incompatible avec les limites de la
planète ajoutant au sentiment
d'incompréhension et de colère la
justice comme objectif et comme mode
d'action et pour nous l'un des leviers
majeurs de la transformation sociale et
la seule façon de repenser les
fondements même de notre politique
économique elle redonne sa légitimité à
la puissance publique sa nécessité à la
planification écologique sa force au
débat
démocratique alors que nos paysans
souffrent chacun le sent l'agriculture
ne traverse pas une simple crise elle
est au cœur d'une révolution à la
confluence de la critique du libéralisme
elle est au cœur de la contestation de
l'exigence de justice et de l'impératif
écologique ce qui sombre c'est une
organisation socio-industrielle fondée
sur l'énergie à Bacou la chimie
l'agrandissement des structures la
spécialisation et un libre échange
destructeur pour ouvrir une nouvelle ère
il faut une refondation de la pâac à
Bruxelles et une vraie loi d'orientation
à Paris nous n'avons ni l'un ni l'autre
un cap l'agroécologie et le
renouvellement des générations un
impératif le juste partage de la valeur
face à la prédation de la grande
distribution et des industries
agroalimentaires une condition la
protection de nos marchés contre une
mondialisation déloyale il n'est plus
possible de faire semblant nous avons
besoin d'une grand d'un grand plan de
bifurcation écologique des
investissements de l'ordre de 100
milliards d'euros par an financé par une
caisse d'amortissement de la dette
climatique nous voulons un plan de
d'rialisation et de décarbonation de
notre industrie garant de notre
souveraineté industrielle et alimentaire
nous devons défendre nos intérêts
souverains préparer l'avenir et
construire l'industrie de demain avec
les ouvriers d'aujourd'hui nous voulons
nous engager résolument dans la
décarbonation de nos modes de vie
planifier les besoins énergétiques
massifier la rénovation thermique
soutenir l'investissement dans les
réseaux et les énergies renouvelables
sansenir soutenir le transport
ferroviaire et fluvial notre écologie
monsieur le Premier ministre c'est
l'écologie des vulnérables une écologie
à hauteur d'homme de la vie quotidienne
qui dessert la ceinture des plus
modestes mieux se loger mieux se
déplacer mieux se nourrir nous voulons
avec les Français plus de justice et
moins de
carbone partout dans le monde Monsieur
le Premier Ministre la dénonciation de
l'injustice l'urgence écologique et le
combat démocratique sont intimement liés
depuis 7 ans l'exécutif n'a cessé de
mépriser le dialogue social de
brutaliser le Parlement d'ignorer les
aspirations profondes des Françaises et
des Français le président de la
République par sa pratique personnelle
naura fini d'épuiser la 5e République et
d'abîmer la politique dans ce que les
citoyens lui conservaiit encore de
crédit il aura manqué de ce type de murs
de vertu de scrupul de sens civique de
respect de l'adversaire qui fonde la
démocratie le président de la République
a oublié les conditions de son élection
face à l'extrême droite toute concession
est une faute morale toute tentative de
triangulation une erreur tactique la
réaction menace gardeous qu' se ser un
jour de l'ordre républicain pour le
retourner contre la République elle-même
monsieur le Premier ministre il n'y a
qu'un pas de la faiblesse à la trahison
ce pas vous l'avez
franchi monsieur le Premier ministre
après c temp de macronisme les
socialistes sont épuisés jamais le défi
inégalitaire n'aura été plus grand ni
l'idéal républicain d'émancipation si
lointain les inégalités explosent les
injustices multiplient les frontières
infranchissables et invisi
quand les incertitudes sont fortes que
l'avenir apparaît sans issue l'entreçoi
devient un refuge chacun défend sa
colère et sa vision du monde il existe
un autre chemin un autre idéal pour y
parvenir tout n'est pas à refaire tout
n'est pas à abat tout est tr main et je
veux dire le sens profond de notre
projet et de notre opposition abattre
les barrières qui partout s'opposent à
la fraternité humaine on me dira que la
fraternité pas un projet politique c'est
le seul qui vaille pour sortir les
hommes et les femmes de la solitude dans
lesquelles les laissent votre politique
votre œuvre destructrice Monsieur le
Premier Ministre abandonne les plus
faibles à ce que vous pensez être leur
destin de perdant je vous ai écouté vous
êtes le jeune visage du vieux
monde